and Halloween Halloween's coming up and
I just can't wait
ooh top scary movies I'm curious what do
you mean top 5 scary movies all time for
people to watch you just bring that up
all this on my thing
you wrote it down yeah yeah bye yeah
it's best workshops in LA read now read
now go read me your list of things that
we were supposed to talk about best
acting workshops ask Bobby my mentor
best acting in industry workshops in LA
I gave you that much then I said remind
Bobby he needs to get to the lighthouse
a 100 dollar contract for someone that
can do that that's there you go and then
I have boo ghost top scary movies you
just came up with that that's great
right there like I don't have a top five
oh I mean my scary movies aren't scary
really to most people what's scary to
you what scared like I think the
notebook is one of the scariest okay
I've ever seen in my life
why because it's fake love it's
unrealistic fake love and I it's so
scary and it scares him because every
girl uses that as a standard for real
love
yeah and it's I hate that you know I
want my man to die at the same exact
time as me when I'm old
[ __ ] you you die I'm free yeah that's
when like wings come and I fly away it's
like the chains are gone no guy is gonna
die with I mean that does happen and
women go all like well you know when
they say old an old man like went a
couple dies like an old man dies and his
wife will die like five days later
that's actually pretty common yeah but
only with men so men die of broken
hearts women don't Wow
so women are less likely to die broken
heart so if the man if the if their if
their husband dies they usually live in
oh when I get married kalila and I die
and I'm up by the pearly gates just like
five days she'll be here and I'm there
for three years
hey Bobby was your a girl oh she's
coming I think okay cuz you know we're
in love we were loved and we were
married you see me hanging Christmas
lights with Tito Ortiz yeah oh my god
beef you me you know what I would do
what I would try to get to like I would
go to Moses I can you help me up with
the meat of Moses
well I had that cup Amina yeah
yeah I was wondering cuz I died we're
married to kalila I know you're very
busy God but um do you I think she
deserves to go to hell is it yeah but
she's a good heart I don't know but look
she's down there with Tito Ortiz and uh
Jenna Jameson's kid yeah oh you take
care of her kids I would be so furious
in fact if I die everybody I know she'd
come to my funeral because if you don't
I'm gonna be watching you tell Moses to
just strike lightning on them ya know
I'm right now George if I died and you
didn't come to my funeral because you
had something else to do trust me you'll
be the first one you see in heaven and
we're gonna have a full-blown argument
like oh why what's up
why'd you come anything uh make maker
studios yeah and in terms of god oh my
god and then he's producing you see from
heaven George producing that fans
podcast
oh I mean don't even talk to me when
you're in heaven then come to heaven I
want to be just family couldn't have an
open funeral because you're a celebrity
I feel like they close those off what do
you mean oh like the closed casket no
like they only certain people in
celebrity funerals by the way I'm gonna
die you're gonna need a closed casket
it's gonna be an eyeball in a foot an
eyeball in a foot what happened he
imploded how just I don't know he did it
floated and you believe yet his diabetes
did it and here's another thing I want
to talk about heaven you Christians out
there mmm and I really mean out you know
what I'm gonna get emotional here I'm
gonna I'm gonna really do it you
Christians out there it doesn't make any
sense that everyone can get to heaven if
you just accept Jesus Christ as your
Lord and Savior okay so it's like
basically telling me is if Jeffrey
Dahmer two weeks before he was murdered
in prison he accepted Jesus Christ as
Lord and Savior he would go to heaven
but if that's the case then what if you
were one of his victims and you're in
heaven - I'll have to see him again
right so you're hanging
out on a cloud with Cleopatra and
Abraham Lincoln you're giggling about
you know something look at custards
Colonel Custer did hairdo and we laugh
you know and all of a sudden Jeffrey
Dahmer rolls by on a cloud was yeah and
then Cleopatra's like what's wrong he
put my thigh in a sandwich he's the one
I killed me yeah my butthole was in his
freezer you know and that's the reason
why I'm here I don't think that that's
cool I think once you cross the line how
about this a religion where you eat
anybody you're automatically going to
have that he'll cannibalism
done no but cannibalism is allowed and
like some some small like subcultures
okay if you can eat you can eat somebody
if they died naturally yeah like there
are i think i think it was in palo where
they used to it was part of the funeral
processor two grieving process to eat
the brains of the deceased and they had
to stop at the World Health Organization
had to stop it because they would they
started getting these uh they're called
like encephalopathies like brain
diseases and it was directly from linked
to eating the brain of the dead I don't
care what kind of people were they call
epochal oppas no those are this a
disease no what are the people called
different Paulo yeah I think they're
from Paulo I'm not sure oh not Vanuatu
one of those I forget no no no they're
from Vanuatu I think yeah not Palo I
feel like your brain would be delicious
George so much knowledge I just feel
like you're smart and they're just I
don't taste I go wow I learned something
new once ate it you too baby I think
that you have a very tasty brain in the
brain you have gray matter and you have
white matter and gray matter is what's
most important its we're all like your
actual like thoughts and everything it's
like that's where all the thinking in
your brain yeah like resides all the
important things who do you think has
the most gray matter I have a lot of
gray matter but my gray matters so like
if you ate my brain you'd be disgusting
you'd be like how that's depressing that
that is very depressing right because
I'm so depressed all the time more gray
matter is good right more gray matter
yeah though I have white matter that a
lot of white matter yeah yeah Gilbert
blank space I also wouldn't even know if
I had to do it on my own like even even
if I could even know what the brain is
like I probably eat the wrong part no
there's no wrong part to eat the brain I
think you would be the most delicious to
eat out of all of us in this room you're
marbling would be really good like Wagyu
he yeah he would be while you for sure
not Kobe yeah yes because he doesn't
move much and you doesn't exercise so
you would be very tender meat so you go
that's tender yeah let's not eat anybody
no it's not dude I was like you my ID
that's the [ __ ] are we talking about I
go straight for your whether scary
movies to notebook is a scariest but
your belly right over ramen noodles oh
that actually sounds delicious
[Music]